[Musique]
et bruno retailleau qui s'installe merci
jean françois husson et bonjour bruno
retailleau bonjour être invités
politiques ce matin êtes sénateur de la
vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain ici au sénat et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes on
intervient en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par christelle
bertrand du groupe la dépêche moins
lourd que celles bonjour ian bonjour
brioches hongrie jours à vous on va
commencer par ce discours de politique
générale qui sera donc prononcé
aujourd'hui par isabelle borne à 15h
devant les députés à 21h devant les
sénateurs qu'allez vous dire ce soir à
la première ministre ce que je vais
demander à la première ministre cdh est
clair de ne pas mentir aux français et
d'avoir un vrai cas parce que le en même
temps à tuer toute cohérence le symbole
d'ailleurs dû en même temps c'est le
nucléaire il ya deux ans il fallait
arrêter 14 réacteurs nucléaires et on à
fermer fessenheim est désormais on va
ouvrir saint-avold c'est à dire une
centrale à charbon voilà qui est très
très très mauvaise cette chance car ban
et situation a changé peut-être est-ce
que cette situation n'a pas changé vous
ne changez pas justement une politique
énergétique comme le nucléaire comme
l'indépendant sa souveraineté
énergétique ça se construit dans le
temps vous ne changez pas de politique
énergétique comme vous changer de
chemise
sur bien sûr l'échec c'est aussi qu'on a
doublé le nombre de jours où en france
on doit importer de l'électricité et
quand on parle d'indépendance
énergétique on est contredit dans les
fêtes donc je vais lui demander un cap
un cap qui soit claire des choix qu'ils
soient nef et je vais lui demander
qu'elle remette de l'or de l'ordre dans
nos finances publiques la france est au
bord de la faillite au bord de la
banqueroute c'est le 3 et banquises et
vous pensez bien sûr le quoi qu'il en
coûte écoutez ça fait le troisième
rapport que la cour des comptes produit
le dernier il ya quelques jours sur
l'exercice 2021 pour nous dire mais ils
ont dépensé sans aucun lien avec la
crise qu'ovide la crise qu fit c'est un
peu moins
hier des dépenses de l'état le reste
c'est l'incurie le reste c'est le
laxisme qui est en train d'en d'été nos
enfants nos petits-enfants donc de
l'ordre justement pas content il était
au bord de la banqueroute comme vous
dites des jeux françois fillon disait
déjà qu'il est à la médiation il a remis
mais depuis rien n'a changé avec
françois hollande mais macron et belle
macro aura dépensé encore plus des
fleurs que françois hollande et au delà
de la crise qu'au budget est pour moi un
bouclier pour protéger nos emplois nos
entreprises mais je vais lui demander
aussi de mettre de l'ordre dans les
esprits il faut pas dire aux français
c'est ce que je dirai la tribune cet
après midi ou ce soir c'est que le quoi
qu'il en coûte certes a coûté en terme
de dépenses publiques il a encore plus
coûter dans les mentalités en faisant
croire aux français que leur sort
individuel ne dépendait que de l'état il
a démobilisé les français un peu comme
jadis il ya vingt ans les 35 heures je
lui demanderais de remettre de l'ordre
dans la rue bien sûr avec un ans
sauvagement de la société avec des
chiffres de monsieur darmanin qui sont
épouvantables que ce soit au point de
vue de la sécurité ou tentatives démis
d'homicides les violences sexuelles et
c'est que ce soit aussi l'ordre à nos
frontières avec une explosion du
phénomène migratoire
donc le bilan est mauvais et je pense
que mails macron quitte aujourd'hui est
dans un trou d'air est sans doute pris
comme d'un vertige parce qu'il sait que
le second quinquennat son second
quinquennat va devoir payer justement
les pots cassés du premier quinquennat
donc voilà je pense que il faut que la
première ministre nous donne un cap on
n'a pas eu le cas pendant la
présidentielle pas de campagne pas de
projet et elle macron indique qu'il
avait un projet clair mais où est ce
projet rien non plus pendant les
législatives donc je demande enfin que
la première ministre nous dise où elle
veut embarquer la france elizabeth ii en
a fait le choix de ne pas solliciter la
confiance des députés cet après-midi ce
que vous comprenez ce choix est ce que
vous regrettez c'est tout simplement
quel acte qu'elle est en position d'une
minorité d'une majorité partons lapsus
révélateur
qui n'est pas une majorité absolue c'est
une situation de fragilité maintenant je
ne vais pas moins
pour une retailleau même si je suis
président de premier groupe au sénat
exiger d'elle ce que la constitution
n'exige pas d'elle mais elle est
politiquement fragile pour vous et les
politiquement fragile et permettez moi
de vous dire que peut-être que la menace
pour elle vient beaucoup plus de
l'intérieur que de l'extérieur elle est
déjà fragilisée par un certain nombre de
ministres régaliens qui s'emploie à lui
scier la branche espérant sans doute
pouvoir lui succéder dans un proche
avenir un sac et je pense à personne
le groupe a l'air à l'assemblée a décidé
de ne pas soutenir la motion de censure
qui a été déposée par la nuque est ce
que vous auriez fait la même chose à
juste raison oui j'aurais fait la même
chose pourquoi j'aurais fait la même
chose parce que c'est une alliance
contre nature parce que nos convictions
sont radicalement opposés fossiles
faut-il rappeler que monsieur mélenchon
avait il ya quelques semaines quelques
mois indiqué que c'était la police qui
tu es non la police et protège les
français les français honnêtes faut-il
rappeler que monsieur mélenchon avec
d'autres de ses affidés ont défilé en
2019 en novembre 2019 avec une
organisation qui était désormais
dissoute parce qu'ils cela mist et dans
cette manifestation les gens criaient
allahu akbhar savez d'islamo gauche ça
veut dire qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'alliance nuque lr sur des thèmes pour
bloquer certains textes non notre ligne
de conduite je l'expliquais ce sera
celle d'une opposition d'intérêt général
nous ne sommes pas macro nist nos
électeurs ne sont pas macro nist nous ne
renieront pas nos convictions ne
trahirons pas nous électeurs en revanche
nous sommes des patriotes nous aimons la
france et par conséquent c'est ce que
l'on fait depuis cinq ans ce qui est
positif ce qui va dans le sens de
l'intérêt suprême du pays nous
l'accompagnons le votre est mais ceci
est ce qu'il peut y avoir une alliance
avec la nuque avec le rn sur des textes
vous avez que vous juge il nous dit
jamais je me situerais par rapport aux
autres moi je me situe par rapport à
notre ligne par rapport à notre
conviction par rapport à ce qui est bon
pour la france mais je dis au
gouvernement jeudi la première ministre
c'est pas dans un seul sens c'est dans
les deux sens combien de propositions on
a fait doux au sénat qui ont été
balayées d'un revers de main je me
souviens pour les handicapés la dea
conjugale isation je me souviens aussi
sur l'islamisme nous avions voté
l'interdiction du port du burkini fille
et on a vu ce que ça donnait à grenoble
nous avions voté aussi le port des
signes ostentatoires religieux dans les
compétitions sportives monsieur darmana
avait balayé ça bien sûr vous allez rien
reverser majeur a bien sûr qu'on leur
propose à bien sûr et j'entends que nous
soyons évidemment mieux écouter
le texte par tex et pas seulement la
capacité
d'amendé des textes que nous présentera
le gouvernement s'est aussi et donc la
capacité que nous entendions les
arguments du gouvernement s'est aussi
linverse c'est que le gouvernement quand
on proposera des propositions de loi il
nous entend un exemple très concret et
des héros y en a dans les campagnes il y
en a déjà remettre dans les villes j'ai
déposé nous avons déposé une proposition
de loi qui permet de remettre en france
4000 jeunes médecins généralistes
dans les déserts médicaux pourquoi est
ce que le gouvernement s'y opposerait ce
matin sur rtl christian estrosi qui est
le maire de nice qui ancien républicain
qui mènerait projet majorité
présidentielle appelle jeune site ses
amis l air à faire une coalition avec la
majorité présidentielle qu'est ce que
vous lui d'abord qui ne parle pas de ses
ennemis et l'air
il était opposant il est un redoutable
adversaire qui attentaient justement de
briser et l'air il a été lui comme
d'autres dans sa région et ailleurs
l'instrument des mâles macron pour la
disparition de l air et simplement je
lui dis mais si demain il y avait une
coalition si demain 10' levions dans le
maquereau ni cela voudrait dire un qu'on
en oublierait toutes nos convictions
mois pour moi l'honneur de la politique
ce sont les conditions certainement pas
les trahisons certainement pas les
rognons mais surtout on abandonnerait si
on donne le monopole de l'opposition à
monsieur mélenchon mm le pen ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que dans cinq ans
l'alternance parce que la démocratie
c'est la possibilité d'alternance ce
serait eux qui auraient ce monopole de
l'alternance c'est ce qu'on veut
vraiment non nous on doit reconstruire
ce sera difficile on a eu une lourde
défaite et moi je ne la sous-estiment
pas il va falloir changer beaucoup
beaucoup de choses dans ce que nous
sommes être sans doute aussi plus humble
plus modestes mais pas modeste vis-à-vis
de nos ambitions certainement pas
le gouvernement bornes de débauchage
bien sûr bien sûr ça signifie que le
pouvoir d'attraction des mails macron
est désormais finie et pas qu'il ya une
volonté peut-être d'emmanuel macron de
pas vous contrarier si je veux dire pour
pouvoir travailler avec vous c'est bien
mal connaître mad men mc ren non non il
a sorti la sens aigu du rapport de force
croyez moi les débauchages c'est ce qui
est d'ailleurs terrible regarder cette
affaire avec damien abad voilà c'est
c'est absolument terrible pour celui qui
joue ce jeu là mais c'est aussi terrible
pour celui qui propose ce des bosseurs
non je peux importe il n'aurait jamais
dû d'ailleurs cette politique de
débauche à choyer qui me révulse et qui
dégoûte les français ont foulé vous que
les français se déplacent pour aller aux
urnes s'ils constatent qu'il ya des gens
qui pendant cinq ans lutte à la tête
d'un groupe à l'assemblée nationale
fermement contre la politique des macros
et qui pour obtenir un maroquin se renie
le lendemain en pleine bataille alors
que ses amis ceux dont il était le
président aller au feu aller au combat
c'est une trahison c'est indécent un
dernier mot sur ce gouvernement est ce
que vous comprenez la promotion gérald
darmanin qui a un ministère élargi l
outre-mer alors que toute la lumière n'a
pas été faite sur ce qui s'est passé au
stade de france incompréhensible ça fait
partie je pense grave erreur de ce
remaniement c'est à dire qu'on conforte
un ministre un ministre qui voit ses
compétences étendues comme aucun autre
ministre de l'intérieur depuis au moins
10 ans et ça veut dire que l macron est
satisfait de lui ça veut dire que il
ratifie
le mensonge il ratifie finalement à
travers ce mensonge la dégradation de
lyme hb de la france rappelez vous
monsieur darmana précisément parce que
il sait parfaitement que le bilan sur
l'insécurité est mauvais il a voulu
cacher ces phénomènes de délinquance et
l'a accusé en réalité les victimes de
liverpool d'être les principaux coûts de
quitter le gouvernement selon je pense
qu'il aurait dû bien sûr le quitter mais
voyez présent république le conforte
celle inverse donc la politique c'est
aussi le sens qu'on donne aux choses
comment voulez vous avoir une politique
de rétablissement de l'ordre public de
fermeté si finalement vous dit et vous
confortez un ministre qui a tout loupé
en matière de sécurité publique encore
une fois ça n'est pas moi qui le dit ce
sont les propres chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur
par l'assemblée très bientôt ian brown
pires et assuré qu'il n'y aurait pas de
retour du pass sanitaire dans le futur
projet de loi est ce que selon vous
c'est une bonne idée c'est une bonne
idée pourquoi c'est une bonne idée parce
que je pense et voyez je suis révolté
j'avais voté le passage finale ou pas
sanitaire expliquez vous le passez
sanitaire moi j'avais voté elle passa ni
terre et elle passe vaccinable par
esprit de responsabilité j'ai eu
énormément doute et je pense que ce vote
là en tout cas le pass vaccinale
a été en rien si j'ose dire dans la
lutte contre le coc vite puisque les
choses étaient déjà derrière nous
lorsque le pass vaccinale a été si j'ose
dire implanté et et crée là bien sûr
nous voterons ce texte c'est un texte
qui est parfaitement technique et c'est
un texte très allégée surtout là on est
à 2000 il faut des mesures plus strictes
il faut des mesures de protection je
pense que le mas transports publics
barrière je pense qu'il faut bien sûr
enfin enfin ce texte reconnaît ce que
nous avions dit ya plus d'un an puisque
souvenez-vous mails macron enfermer les
français chez eux et ouvrez les
frontières l'a heureusement on va exiger
le pass sanitaires aux frontières et
dans un certain nombre de mouvements
entre la métropole des outre mer ou ou
la corse et au moins on n'enferme pas
les français c'est des frontières qu'il
faut protéger donc voilà donc y aura pas
de polémique sur ce texte là c'est un
texte régit
les transports et le bombé à moi je suis
favorable en tout cas au moins en
matière de responsabilité mais je suis
favorable à ce qui est ce genre de
mesures qui soient des mesures fondées
sur la responsabilité encore une fois
mais il faut faire attention on a
énormément de cas de contamination
très vite hier emmanuel macron a réuni
son gouvernement pour parler de ce texte
sur le pouvoir d'achat qu'est ce que
vous en attendez vous
ce que j'en attends c'est que l'on mette
fin au quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est à dire au grand mensonge au grand
mensonge des français vis-à-vis des
traitements la fille consiste à dire que
qui consiste à dire que l'état peut tout
que l'état est responsable du pouvoir
d'achat on peut pas encore une fois bull
type lier les chèques sur la dette
j'attends aussi qu'on dise aux français
avec ce langage de vérité que le pouvoir
d'achat ne peut venir que du travail et
qu' il faut faciliter précisément
contre par exemple ce que je nous allons
conditionné nous allons conditionner
notre faute à deux mesures de fond parce
qu'il faut revenir aux causes plutôt que
d'essayer comme on fait en france depuis
des années des années de traiter les
conséquences de ces causes avec toujours
plus d'argent public première première
condition on veut du travail on veut que
le travail paye parce que le pouvoir
d'achat c'est d'abord le salaire et donc
par exemple non seulement la
défiscalisation de toutes les heures au
dessus des 35 heures de 35 ha à 39 ou 40
heures mais l'exode les rations des
charges sociales pour les entreprises et
ça ça permet quand vous passez de 35
heures à 39 heures sous ce régime là
avantageux pour l'entreprise avantageux
pour le salarié vous obtenez un salaire
net pour les petits salaires de 1500
euros ont envoyé du ps notre différence
eux ils veulent voilà un chèque et nous
ont dit ok on peut arriver à 1510 euros
par mois mais avec plus de travail
première chose et deuxième chose la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte parce que on est
un état désormais en faillite au bord de
la banqueroute
les taux d'intérêt sont folles l'euro
est en train de dévisser et la
croissance est en train de flancher ça
veut dire des économies donc nous en
ferons pas je le dis à votre antenne
nous ne voterons pas ce texte s'il n'y a
pas de mesures d'économies nous avons
fait une proposition
nous en ferons d'autres la proposition
qui est une proposition fondamental
c'est pour mettre fin à la fraude
sociale vous avez près de 8 millions de
cartes vitale en france en plus qu'il ya
deux français des milliards des
milliards d'euros de dépenses de fraude
eh bien nous voulons nous l'avons déjà
vote au sénat la carte vitale
biométrique et nous ferons d'autres
propositions mais moi je dis finalement
comme le pression de république présent
république a dit écoutez ondes financera
ni par de nouveaux impôts ni par un
nouvel endettement pas moi je l'écouté
j'espère quand même que le gouvernement
ne l'a écoutée en tiendra compte le
groupe plr a fait une proposition qui
est de plafonner à 1 euro 50 le prix de
l'essence à la pompe à ce que vous
partagez cette proposition
50 ce type de blocage des prix peut
conduire à une dépense précisément très
important en revanche en revanche
olimar les questions salette nous avons
discuté à parler non pas d'un blocage 1
euro 50 il a parlé d'un objectif en
revanche nous convergeront sur des
mesures qui sont des mesures de bon sens
nous ne voulons plus de taxes sur les
taxes on a une tva aujourd'hui qui est
fixe celle là contrairement à l'autre
sur la tei c'était une texte sur les
taxes quand on est droite on n'aime pas
bien la fiscalité et le matraquage
fiscal donc ça on proposera l'annulation
ces 4 milliards et ses 14 centimes du
litre qui pourraient s'ajouter à dhuisy
centimes on peut aussi faire d'autres
propositions par exemple revaloriser les
indemnités kilométriques pour ceux qui
payent hier pépé et en faire un impôt
négatif
c'est-à-dire avec une aide pour ceux qui
ne paient pas l'ir pp donc je pense
qu'il ya des solutions qui sont
intelligentes et qui préserve aussi la
responsabilité et la dépense publique
donc la différence entre la position du
groupe nr là dessus et à l'assemblée
elle est pas très grave parce que on
converge sur le travail on converge sur
les dépenses publiques et sur les moyens
nous convergeons ont convergé sur les
moyens j'en ai parlé dans le détail et
je pense que ce que je viens de vous
dire le groupe des députés sera d'accord
avec ses moyens à marseille tu es le
président du groupe centriste au sénat
il est favorable à une taxation des
supers profits pour les énergéticiens
voit aussi
à voir moi tout ce qui est à que je me
méfie d'autant plus que pour la plupart
total de ces profits les faits à
l'étranger donc
je pense que laurent sera très très
faible et pour ce qui concerne d'edf edf
est taxé à travers à travers un
mécanisme terrible de l'arenh
c'est-à-dire il doit subventionner ses
concurrents différents décomptes une
entreprise qui france ivan ses
concurrents edf est en train d'aller
dans le mur et si justement veut une
indépendance énergétique
il va falloir reconstruire sur de bonnes
bases edf un mois sur une autre
actualité r16 mer et trente cinq mineurs
ont été rapatriés de cire et c'est le
premier rapatriement aussi massif depuis
la chute en 2019 de l'état islamique est
ce que vous approuvez cette décision
dont je ne trouve pas dans sa méthode
puisque le gouvernement vient de changer
de pied avant c'était le cas par cas je
l'avais approuvé cette politique du cas
par cas notamment en fonction de la
dangerosité on rapatrie pas sur le sol
français parce qu'il faut préserver des
français n'importe qui n'importe comment
le gouvernement l'a fait en catimini
mais sur le fond je pense que ce sont
des gens aient regardé dans
adulte il ya emilie koenig qui est
depuis 2012 l'une des plus recherchés en
tout cas mais des plus dangereuses elle
a laissé ses deux maisons fait
est là à l'époque en bretagne elle a
laissé je crois deux enfants de trois et
de cinq ans et les abandonner pour aller
lutter contre la france ces gens là sont
coupables de trahison d'intelligence
avec l'ennemi là vous demandez en mesure
particulière par exemple non jeu non non
j'aurais souhaité qu'il reste là bas oui
mais maintenant qu'elle est en france
aujourd'hui elle est mise en examen
placé en détention qu'est ce que vous
demandez je demande de vraiment mais la
plaine la plus lourd on ne doit plus la
retrouver en liberté une ben saada
décelable a été condamné à la perpétuité
réelle c'est josiane incompressibles il
ya quelques jours et est franchement le
travail de la justice que je saluais
vraiment dans ce cas du jugement des
acteurs de l'attentât de novembre 2015
du bataclan a été exemplaire mais
justement au nom de toutes les victimes
au nom de tous les policiers les
gendarmes qui lutte contre l'islamisme
en france on n'a pas le droit justement
au laxisme donc et make any d'autres
auraient dû rester là bas et bien sûr ce
que je demande c'est la fermeté qu'elle
ne se retrouve pas demain en liberté
parce qu'on sait parfaitement que la
déradicalisation c'est pas un problème
psychiatrique on est choqué aujourd'hui
est ce que le problème réussi dans les
expériences qui ont été menées aucune
des radicalisations ce sont des bombes
humaines qu'on me comprenne bien moi ma
fonction j'ai été élu par des français
je veux protéger mes compatriotes c'est
le mandat qui m'a été donnée ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui le problème de ces
revenons et de ces djihadistes qui vont
sortir de prison n'est pas réglé bien
sûr que non birkin et non il est même
pas à régler il est aujourd'hui accrue
le prix est sur les nerfs le président
des républicains
eh non on va donc quitter ses fonctions
très bientôt est ce que vous serez
candidat à la succession de christian
jacob
en tout cas ça sera une étape importante
pour notre vie politique un lourd échec
et il faut tout changer je pense qu'on
est en assez d'accord on a beaucoup
beaucoup décourager nos nos électeurs
depuis des années des années qu'ils ne
nous ont pas jugées dignes de confiance
donc ça quand je parlais d'humidité
voyez quand je parlais de modestie vous
ne répondez pas à la question je vous
réponds dit je pense qu au moment où je
vous parle je pense que celui qui peut
le mieux être à même de relever le défi
d'une reconstruction c'est laurent
wauquiez je le lui dis et je l'aiderai
il est en ébullition il est en réflexion
les réflexions et nous verrons bien
après je prendrai ma décision avec lui
et quelques autres puisque au monde à
quel stade
en fonction de sa propre décision de six
jours je consulte aussi david lisnard et
quelques autres qui vous est donnée
resteriez quand est ce qu'ils essaient
de le dire mais ça veut dire que
question d'attendre après l'été ce sera
trop tard on est en situation
aujourd'hui christian jacob nous a
quittés donc il nous avait prévenus
d'ailleurs le 1er juillet annie genevard
assure l'intérim mais il ya un angle
mort évidemment il faut réduire il faut
raccourcir ce délai parce que on voit
bien que la situation politique
française à l'émouvante donc esp celui
qui prend la tête du parti donc laurent
wauquiez c'est ce que vous souhaitez
doit être votre candidat à la
présidentielle pour vous ce sont deux
choses différentes je pense qu'il ya non
je pense qu'on doit pouvoir construire à
la fois une candidature pour la
présidentielle à partir du parti
politique c'est pas une obligation mais
je pense que ce serait mieux merci bruno
retailleau merci vous viendrez nous en
parler évidemment la rentrée merci
merci d'avoir été notre invité au regard
de la une de la dépêche et c'est ce qui
s'est passé du côté de tarbes deux
enseignants tué par balles hier c'est à
la une de la dépêche aujourd'hui merci
creissels merci bruno retailleau
[Musique]